hey guys it's Thursday May 28th I'm Mary
Kish and this is gamespot news the show
that's guaranteed to be informative and
attempts to be funny normally that's my
job as the host but today we have an
intern go get me something funny first
up it looks like one of Microsoft's
super secret III announcements might
have been spoiled because a new Xbox
controller has been found amongst the
Xbox support website so what's the big
freaking deal well the new controller
features a 3.5 millimeter headphone port
at its base a line from the description
explains that the port will only be
available on controllers released after
June 2015
currently Xbox one owners have to buy a
headset adapter to hook up headsets
they can set you back around 25 bucks so
including this little guy is a pretty
big fix the timing would suggest an
announcement at Microsoft's e3 briefing
next month although this has not been
confirmed there are only two types of
people I don't trust in this world
people who don't like three games and
people who don't like gluten spaghetti
is awesome if you don't like either of
those things you might not like this
next news story I said funny not scary
Xbox one gold members just found out
what games they're getting free next
month with the main one being Double
Fine's massive chalice this is the debut
for the turn-based strategy game about
making a successful nation while
battling the cadence and makin babies
Xbox one owners also get pool nation
effects cool Xbox 360 owners get Just
Cause 2 from June 1st through the 15th
Bennet will be replaced by thief for the
rest of the month we're slowly but
surely narrowing down the release date
for uncharted 4 a thief's end we knew it
was in 2016 and now we know its before
April PlayStation President Andrew house
included the game on a slide during his
recent Investor Day presentation for the
fiscal year 2015
Sony's fiscal 2015 ends March 31st 2016
so with our powerful reasoning and
deductive logic we can assume the
will come out between January and March
of 2016
take that Sherlock there was another
slide showing that project morpheus is
due to launch before June and that's
right around the time that oculus rift
is releasing fight fight fight fight
after a successful release and obtaining
coveted score of 10 on GameSpot calm CD
Projekt RED continues to release SiC
trailers of The Witcher 3 rubbing the
gorgeous dirt and gamers everywhere who
still haven't purchased I said funny not
funny looking a new video released
Thursday titled beautiful world of The
Witcher highlights the RPGs massive open
world on displays the game's sprawling
and varied environments including snowy
mountains clear streams and rivers
populated cities and lush forests it's
so lush CD Projekt Reds gone through a
lot of effort here to showcase the game
but sadly these videos are no match for
the number one reason people search
YouTube for The Witcher the nudie boobie
secks seems finally FIFA 16 will be
featuring women's teams for the first
time making it the most realistic
version of FIFA yes now all it needs to
do is include bribery human trafficking
money laundering and a buttload of money
built upon blood of poor people there
will be 12 international women's teams
to be playable in EAS FIFA offering for
this year the inclusion isn't a mere
rescanning of existing players which
would be really strange according to
FIFA 16 producer Nick Shannon new
technology including animations body
types and even hair physics had to be
retooled or created from scratch to
accommodate the introduction of female
players but why is now a good time to
introduce ladies in the game Nick
Shannon simply states it's the right
time because we were able to get the
technology in place to do it properly
it's as simple as that
like putting like putting the bump here
and doubling it and putting it here is
super hard also you don't need boobie
physics they're gonna wear sports bras
this is the first of many steps EA will
have to take to no longer be known as
the emperor palpatine of the game
development world so that's all the news
I have for you today but be sure to
check back tomorrow we'll all be
rounding up the top 5 stories of the
week
what's this you ass clown Dyer go what
the [ __ ] is your problem
okay seriously we have a [ __ ] intern
here you can't confer you can't treat
like [ __ ] you can't treat like septum
bladder okay we have a few system here a
system of rules that you follow and you
obey every [ __ ] thing I say or you're
[ __ ] out of here okay